our testers Michele and Andre can't
decide who will conduct today's test
drive so they play rock-paper-scissors
to choose no wonder they both wanted to
drive this Porsche Panamera Turbo as
executive generates a whopping 419
kilowatts of power the car not only
sounds impressive it looks impressive
too designed as a chauffeur-driven model
for the asian market this extended
version boasts even more luxury and
comfort than standard Panamera's michele
ass where they should go
Andres hungry so he suggests they head
for a Chinese restaurant he knows it's
far away but they can test drive the car
and route and then picked up some
noodles going on long road trips isn't a
problem in the Porsche Panamera Turbo s
executive not only is it comfortable to
ride in its powerful motor makes the
journey go quicker those who like to
listen to some engine noise on the way
can pump up the volume at the push of a
button
Michele asks if Andre knows he's sitting
in the turbo s executives best seat the
back right one
Andre says that's interesting right now
he's more interested in sitting in the
driver's seat so Michele offers to
change places still Andre had it pretty
good in the backseat your passengers can
watch films or play music using the
displays mounted on the front seat
headrests and there's plenty of room to
stretch out and relax the whole interior
loses luxury boasting plenty of weather
as well as chrome and wood accents
outside the sedans rear-end is rather
simple only the dual twin tube fail
pipes and a large portion earring hint
at the power of the Panamera Turbo S and
the extended executive version has a 15
centimeter longer wheelbase compared to
the regular Turbo S
in spite of its length this Porsche can
accelerate from zero to 100 kilometres
an hour in just 3.9 seconds maximum
torque is 750 newton meters this super
luxury car comes fully loaded with all
kinds of safety systems and driver
assists Porsches dynamic chassis control
an active anti-roll system that reduces
lateral body movement when cornering and
active suspension management come as
standard making for a silky smooth ride
so Michelle wonders why she hasn't seen
any Panamera Turbo S executives on
German roads on delay explains that this
extended version was conceived as a
chauffeur-driven model for the Asian
market he thinks Germans and most other
Europeans who have a Porsche prefer to
drive it themselves now it's time for
them to stop and eat
yup slices Michelle asked whether a
chauffeur-driven sedan really needs to
be so sporty Honda Li says honestly no
it's completely superfluous he thinks
people who want to be driven around are
looking for a comfy ride not to be
thrown from side to side this Porsche is
purely about prestige